knowledge is in my opinion the most
important asset it's invaluable followed
by data yes your list yeah yeah yeah
correct money in the bank everyone
thinks oh how do you get into property
with no money it's like money is not
even that important what's important is
your knowledge and your data correct I
would rather you wipe my bank account to
zero then you wipe my list to zero
exactly I got over a 100,000 investors
on my database that went down to zero I
would be absolutely gutted you know what
I'm saying the only thing worse than why
in my list to zero would be wiping my
knowledge yeah cuz now I don't know how
to even effectively use my list money is
the least important asset